las vegas landed its first major  international event that doesn't come  here without allegiant stadium  the concacaf gold medal game the  championship is coming to las vegas  this is a premier soccer event and the  title game will be played  at allegiant stadium on august 1st this  doesn't happen without that stadium  stadium was a game changer for the  destination completely opening us  up to host international type events  like this concrete gold cup  finals you know ncaa potentially the  final four  maybe the super bowl at some point in  time but without that 65 000 seat  stadium  we don't have those events in las vegas  which are huge economic impact drivers  for us  driving tourism creating jobs for the  local economy  and then putting all eyes globally on  the brand of las vegas so game changer  all around